hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar disease modeling and cancer
therapy and stem cell derived 3d
organoid systems
I am Alexis Krause of leopards and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab birds and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher com
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
once there's many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask question
box located on the far left of your
screen this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
dr. devon julie dutta postdoctoral
researcher kubrick institute hans
cleaver lab dr. Dutta is currently
pursuing her postdoctoral research in
the lab of Professor Hans cleavers
Netherlands where she is using human
tissue derived 3d organized cultures to
study host microbiome interactions
infectious diseases and cancer for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr. Gupta you may now begin
your presentation
thank you so much for the introduction
and thank you all for joining me for
this webinar I'm a postdoc in Hans
cleavers group and today I will be
talking about how the 3d or binoy system
can be used for disease modeling as well
as cancer therapy so what exactly are
organized so I mean very broadly
speaking organize our 3d stem cell
tissue drive structures or as we call
them the mini organs in a dish
these mimic the in vivo architecture of
tissues structurally functionally as
well as genetically and because of these
features the organize provides really
powerful means 4xp were modeling as an
in vitro model system for census
research and also in developmental
biology a temporal organoids
can be developed from two different
kinds of stem cells and very broadly
again they can be either pre potent stem
cell derived organoid which are
basically embryonic stem cells or
induced pluripotent stem cell derived
organoids and adult stem cells arrived
organized and I will be talking about
these a bit more in detail in the coming
slides but just to give you an overview
of how many kinds of organize have been
developed already and here you see a
panel of organize so from the adult stem
cells we have isolated and devlog
intestinal organized liver organized
ovarian organized lung organoids
whereas from the prepotent stem cells
again liver stomach are even kidney
organized having develop brain organized
have been developed which have been used
recently for Zika virus infection
studies and also other sensory organ oil
so what exactly or how are these people
in stem cell derived organoids develop
so this is a schematic showing how they
are actually generated so the green
potent stem cells are first grown in lab
as embryo bodies or the spheroid and
these are pluripotent in nature
basically they are derived from master
cells as we call them because these can
actually differentiate in transform any
kind of cell type that is in theory the
idea or behind a pluripotent stem cell
so when these are grown and
bodies or sparrows in the tissue culture
depending on what kind of signals are
provided to them like differentiation
signals they can be differentiated into
different kinds of tissue and these when
they are embedded with the matrigel in
3d these can form the specialized organ
oil
whereas the adult stem cell organoids
are somewhat more defined because they
are already isolated from the tissue of
origin for example in this case what I'm
showing you is like a an intestinal
biopsy and what we do is we get a biopsy
we mince the tissue into small pieces
and then I finally I either isolate the
crypts from the intestine or we kind of
make them into single cells which are
then plated in 3d in matrigel
which is an extracellular matrix and
within two to three days we already see
these organoids growing and most of the
work that I showed today is based on
that a stem cell derived organize
because these are the organize that we
use in our lab in the flavours lab for
all the studies so what are these
organized exactly so these organize that
I'm talking about the adult tissue
derive organize are mostly epithelium in
a region they do not have any reason Chi
Manish person and they are grown in an
extracellular matrix which provides them
with a lot of factors to help them grow
this can be either mid mutt Roger the
basement membrane extract or recently we
have also used a synthetic hydrogen
which is essentially polyethylene glycol
and this is important because both
nitrogen and DME are not very much
defined because they are isolated from
the sarcoma cells of the mouse whereas
if there is a synthetic hydrogel which
is more defined in characteristics then
the studies are also way more defined
and one more important aspect of these
organelles are that they can be kept in
culture for extended periods of times or
sometimes or most of them actually have
been grown for more than a year in
culture and they maintain all the
genetic structure of or genetic basis as
well
structure and all the functions and here
is a picture which basically shows you
how from a single cell at d0
the cell then device form these small
organoids and by day 13 response the
fully full organoid respond with a basal
lateral as well as tactical polarity so
it is important also to note that
organized some have polarity mostly the
interior or the lumen side of the
organoids are apical in nature whereas
the outside is more vessel lateral in
nature so next we will see a video which
basically will give you an idea of how
these organized ar.drone
these organized as I should I start they
basically start as single cell and in
culture they grow into these big
organize and then they need to be
sheared we using trypsin and then again
plated with Matra gel so that they grow
and can be expand expanded for long
periods
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what you saw just now is how the
organoids are grown and expanded in
culture right so what is also again
important to know is that the organoid
are really like a mini organ so when
they are grown in expansion media these
are the e/m we call them as DM so these
essentially have a stem cell-like
characteristics and that is why they
expand in cultures that's how you see
when you Tristan eyes them and then you
again play them and they keep growing
and if you want to really differentiate
them into a certain cell type then you
have to put them in differentiation
media this is by either withdrawing some
factors like for example in the case of
intestinal stem cells organoids you have
to withdraw the wind so that they kind
of become more differentiated in
characteristics and so on for different
ultimate culture so we call them as
expansion media and differentiation
media two different kinds of media and
here what I'm showing you is when you
put these organoids in differentiation
media they kind of form different cell
types here in mark and outline
phosphatase are the intro sites music
producing goblet cells and so on so the
alternate technology there are lots of
applications of organoid technology
first application is bio banking of
patient-derived organoids so bio banking
is basically like a bank so you can go
there and you have like a panel of
organoids derive from patient material
of different individuals and these can
be used for drug testing or for disease
modeling we have also used tumor and
cystic fibrosis organized to test
different drugs and also we can do host
microbe introduction studies using these
organized and I will be talking mostly
about disease modeling of cancer along
with a little bit of host microbe
interaction studies and how also a bio
banking of patient derive organizer is
being done and how all of these together
can be brought into a co-culture system
so
the organoid system health and
personalized therapy or personalized
cancer treatment the first benefit of
having organizers that most of the cell
lines that have been used in late are
cancerous but we do not really have a
baseline or a healthy tissue but for
organized what we do is when we get a
patient material we isolate the tissue
from the healthy part of the tissue as
well as the cancerous part and as a
result we have organoids of the same
patient from the cancerous tissue as
well as the healthy tissue
so these orgonites are all genetically
characterized so we basically can go
back and correlate which kind of
mutations are present and how these
organizers are responding to drug
therapy and as I said they can be
cryopreserved and also expanded and kept
in culture for extended periods of time
they can be used again and again for
various disease and disease testing and
drug testing how do these help actually
in drugs I isiliye are mean by figuring
out what kind of drug is actually good
for a certain patient so here in this
picture you see for example we have
three drugs drug a drug B and drug team
C out of this when we test it does all
these drugs on the patient draw our eyes
organized as well as the cancer
organoids
drug it kills both the healthy as well
as the cancerous organoid however drug B
and C selectively kills the cancer
organoid which bigger shows us kind of
that this is a good target or these two
drugs can potentially be drugs which can
be used for therapy and but one thing
that obviously we all know is that the
drugs which mostly fail the clinical
trial phase is because they cause liver
toxicity and so we again bring in the
liver organized at this stage and if we
test these drugs for example from our
first screen we know drug B and drugs C
were good or potential drugs for this
patient and then we check for liver
toxicity and here we see that while drug
B doesn't cause any liver
the D drug C does and so we come to the
conclusion that for this specific
patient drug B is probably the best
combination or the best drug that can be
provided so delivered by of living bowel
banks of cancer organized have been
developed the first living biobank that
was developed in our lab was in the
colorectal cancer biobank and recently
we have also developed a breast cancer
organoid biobank and this was developed
from 150 patient samples and this list
shows all the different types of cancers
which have been created as bio banks and
which can be obtained and also different
deaths can be performed on these
recently in a lab we have also developed
a new system which is the lung organoid
system and we call them as the human
every organoid and these can be used for
both cancer as for cystic fibrosis
modeling these carry all the cell types
the basal cells the club cells and the
ciliate itself and we are also in the
process of developing a cancer lung
cancer bio bank which will also be
available for testing different kinds of
drugs in the future so till now I have
been talking about how we isolate the
castle cancerous tissue and then develop
them into organized but we can also do
it the other way around basically we can
model cancer using healthy organized
about making mutations in them so this
was in a paper published in 2015 where
we used CRISPR cast 9 to induce
mutations in the healthy organoid and we
could follow these different different
mutations so basically a single mutation
was first created and then these mutated
organoids were selected then the second
mutation was added and so on and it was
found that while a single mutated single
gene mutated organoid did not really
lead to mitosis whereas a quadruple
mutant which had four mutations this
lead to
metastasis and was much more like a
malignant in nature
and so this is another aspect of cancer
modeling which can be used or useful in
lab for cancer modeling but when we talk
about like the human body as I said
these organelles are mostly epithelial
in nature we should not forget that our
body actually has the gut that is
repetier themselves the microbes and
also the immune cells so if we really
want to recapitulate the in vivo
environment we need to add immune cells
as well as the microbes into this and so
the idea is to have a triple Co culture
system and the recent branch of cancer
therapy which is much very much in use
today is cancer immunotherapy and the
2018 Nobel Prize went to dr. Alton and
dr. Jeff casue for their work on
immunotherapy in your therapy is
essentially modeling or kind of inducing
your in the old immune cells to target
the cancer tissue and we think that with
a triple co-culture system of organized
immune cells as well as the microbiome
we might be able to help this field of
immunotherapy and how we will be plan to
do that what I will explain now so this
is a model of how we think the crypto
culture system should look like so first
with the organoid we plan to add the
immune cells isolated from the same
donor so basically the immune cells from
the same patient from whom we have
isolated the organoid tissue for the
organoid and then add the bacteria or
the commensal bacteria into the organoid
human so as to have all three components
together and and this idea was tested
recently in collaboration with another
lab where it was shown that the tumor
reactive T cells when they are cultured
with tumor cells and healthy cells
poteete cells which were when they are
cultured together basically they react
with the tumor organoids and they lead
to the death of the tumor organize
however they do not cause any death in
the healthy
organoid and this is a picture showing
the same on the left you see healthy
organized which were exposed to a lot of
t-cells and this is in the presence of a
green fluorescent gas base for a pro so
essentially all the cells if the eye is
very seldom it will light up as green
and on the left is other control cells
along with immune cells there was no
cell that whereas when there are tumor
organoids and T cells are added a green
fluorescence signal was observed
basically showing that this Co culture
of immune cell evade the tumor organized
is very much efficient in recapitulating
the in vivo architecture and also in
vivo functioning now at the same time
what we were also developing is how and
how can we get the microbes into the
organize because the microbes as I said
are very present on the epical side and
for master intestinal organized mostly
that cool site is on the interior part
and so we have desert this new technique
which is basically microinjection of the
microbes into the organoid lumen and
here you see an organized which is
injected with microbes and we add a
green dye so that we can visualize and
see which organs have been injected or
not and below is an example of presently
labeled bacteria injected into the
ordinary human and as you see this is
visible not only 3 hours later but also
for extended periods of time
so when we wanted to check like if our
Arco culture of bacteria and organize is
actually functional or not what we did
was we first tested a pathogenic
bacteria and we injected Shigella which
is pathogenic bacteria known to induce
cell death in in in vivo and what you
see here is when we injected the control
organoid with a with normal PBS there
was no effect however when we injected
them with the pathogenic bacteria there
was a massive cell death and complete
disruption of the orgonite architecture
this was our proof of concept that
indeed a whole culture of organized with
the microbes would work we extended our
study and of course it was important for
us to also somehow let the anaerobic
bacteria also survive in the organoid
lumen and for that we have now set up
conditions by which we can grow these
anaerobic bacteria inside the organ
hardly mean for extended periods of time
and here you see colony forming assays
for different bacteria and the fact that
they actually grow both in expansion and
differentiation media they are able to
survive in the organism as again a proof
of concept what we did was we added the
immune cells and here in the picture you
see on the left a control organoid
without any virus and surrounded by the
surrounding the organoid are the immune
cells whereas on the infected panels you
see in green the virus which was added
to the organoid and as soon as the virus
was added you see a massive influx of
the immune cells who was the infected
organoid and so this was a proof of
concept of like a first triple culture
model where we brought in the epithelial
organoids
a microbe and the immune cells and now
right now what we are developing in lab
is the cool culture the set of the tumor
organoid blood lymphocytes and the
commensal microbes
so I'll quickly summarize what I told
you today so organoids our mini organs
in a dish can be dead block from pure
potent stem cells or adult stem cells
organized have been established from
multiple organs which include the
intestine the kidneys brain liver
stomach pantries ovaries and lung
organoids
can be used for multiple clinical
applications including disease modeling
for drug screening for various host
microbe interaction studies and for
regenerative therapy we can also
manipulate genes or perform gene editing
using CRISPR cast mind as I showed like
we can sequential mutate different genes
and this will again enable disease
modeling and targeted gene therapy we
have now been able to show that a whole
culture of tumor organoids along with
these cells leads to tumor reactive T
cells also Co cultures of microbes
winter organize has shown that there is
a complex interplay between the microbes
and the epithelium and we are we can do
this for not just like one tissue but
for brain stomach and intestine and
various different tissues and finally I
think what is very important is
development of our triple Co culture
system which will help us figure out how
exactly what exactly goes on inside the
body and I think that will be the future
of organization with this I would like
to take questions thank you so much
Thank You dr. Becker for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the five left to your screen and well
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started
our first question is
are the organized developed in the
cleavage labs available to other
researchers on request yes absolutely so
we have a foundation called who parade
organoid technology where we have a
large collection of these living bio
bands and we have bio banks for cancer
or the noise from colon prostate lung
pancreas and breast cancer as well as
from cystic fibrosis patients and all
these organizers are characterized by
genome sequencing expression profiling
and also the sensitivity of known drugs
have been established and big databases
linking the genetic and transcriptional
information to the regular drug drug
response is known so yes absolutely so
if somebody wishes to use these
organoids they need to write to the who
provide technology and the further
processing will be done from there
onwards
now our next question is is a two-part
question do you feed the bacteria and
what are they're called what are their
carbon sources
I'll feed the bacteria when we inject
them and that's what I understand so so
the way these bacteria are growing also
depends to the anaerobic bacteria or the
pathogenic bacteria so these are
basically grown on the place I like the
elbe place or the data car place in the
case of anaerobic bacteria that's how we
grow them engines before injecting we
put them into capillaries and that's and
we put them in capillaries and we
suspend them in the media itself or the
brought that they were grown in and yes
so all the constants which are actually
used for growing the bacteria in general
are also included in the liquid that we
inject and definitely that's why we do
feed the bacteria somewhat when we
inject them once they go inside the
bacteria I think they take up sources
from the media components and also from
yeah but whatever we have added to the
media of borrowing to organize
now are there studies showing that
normal tissue derived organoids can
undergo neoplastic transmits
transformation in vitro
so we have been able to show that so
where we isolate the tissue and grow
them as normal healthy organoids and we
keep them in culture for at least twenty
six twenty seven passages and then we
again check them for sniff and a by snip
analysis and whole genome sequencing and
they have never been by these small
aberrations but there's no a very
significant of development of any
mutation or any kind of aberration in
the organoids
so I mean I think I don't I'm not sure
of any study which has completely and
only focused on this but our results
from our results in the lab we
consistently see no such thing happening
you
in the context of tumor 3d cell culture
how it organized different from steroids
abscess is also technically spares are
also somewhat 3d in nature
I think the way they are grown is
already different because in the 3d
organize we grow them in a Matra gel
trough and we provide them in different
factors Faro is also our 3d and the only
difference I think the major difference
is also about about the fact that the
spirits are isolated and they cannot be
isolated from healthy human tissue
whereas organoids can be and that
already puts organoids a bit at a higher
pedestal because I think for any kind of
drug testing you really need to have a
healthy and a tumorous tissue whereas
from at least till now i atill did i
don't think they have been able to grow
the normal spheroid normal healthy
tissue spheroid
now dr. Dutta our next question have you
tried culturing organoid excuse me
organoid and scaffolds instead of
matrigel and do you have any preference
yeah absolutely so there was a paper
from our lab and also from matheus
Newton's lab from epfl where we tested
designer matrices as we call them and
these are essentially polyethylene
glycol and these were shown to really
help the growth of the organize and it
was also shown that different elasticity
of the matrices matters in terms of stem
cell proliferation and also for the
differentiation and yeah so these are
being developed so these are called
polyethylene glycol hydrogel and these
we are definitely looking forward to
these because right now the
extracellular matrix that has views is
my teacher or a basement membrane
extract and these are isolated from the
sarcoma of mice and so they are actually
isolated from mice and it's not very
defined of course because it you know
vary from batch to batch and if we can
have these designer matrices or
synthetic hydro gels as we call them
then it will be really a way more
defined and we will know what exactly
are the root factors important so as we
are developing that along with the new
toss-up right now yes
most of the organoids are made on match
drills
however in the case of pancreatic cancer
there are lots of collagen around the
tumor cells do you really think that
major gel alone can reflect the real
physiological situation in our hands
when the tumor cells grow in collagen or
nature gel they have very different
morphology okay um so I am NOT an expert
in bang critic cancer but I can say for
sure that the people who are doing this
research in our lab definitely use
matrigel
or basement membrane extract and we have
never used collagen so I will not be
able to say how different they are
morphologically that in that sense but
we definitely compare it to the tissue
of the pancreatic tissue from which the
organoids were derived and they
definitely look like the tissue of
origin so I think it's important to
compare these two and I am we are right
now developing monolayers where I think
monolayers we use collagen but then of
course mole Anton monolayers look very
different from 3d organize in general so
because collagen is in our lab at least
used for making monolayers and not
really organoid but yeah what I can say
about pancreatic cancer is the build the
Cal organoids look very similar to the
cancer of origin yeah
we are getting so many good questions
today so just as a reminder for our
audience any questions that we do not
have time for today will be answered via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration so
let's continue with our next question
how many bacteria are you using together
so that's the thing so ideally what we
plan to do is so if we started with
injecting one bacterial species at a
time because the idea was to really see
what each individual's bacteria
commensal bacteria and how does to the
epithelium and how the epithelium and
the bacteria interact and so now we have
been able to show that the single single
bacterial species definitely grow and
now we are trying to include multiple
combinations and we are looking at
literature to see which kind of
commensals kind of help each other or
potentiate each other and we are trying
to do it in different combinations now
and I think eventually when I talk about
the triple co-culture system it would
have to include probably the whole
microbiome whatever I mean it's not hold
that most of the species of the
microbiome which is I am which are
isolated from the patient fecal matter
yeah so this is where we are right now
but yeah I think it's the long way to go
definitely we will have to compare lots
of different combinations to come to a
conclusion now in your organ or in you
know Camino culture do you have to
activate the immune cells and stimulate
them yes definitely so so what we do is
you have to sew the paper which I
mentioned in my talk so they what they
do is they activate the immune cells so
that they kind of become responsive a by
using antigens and then they are placed
in co-culture with the tumor cells and
way studies have been in has been done
to check if it is causing some kind of
unnatural activation of T cells but it
doesn't because still the T cells
definitely attack only the tumor cells
and not the normal normal organoids so
yes we do artificially have or we have
to activate the T cells to get the
population of T cells which actually are
tumor responses
/ - that our next question - all
organized have an apical our excuse me
an optical interior and a basal exterior
so all organized definitely have
polarity very specific polarity but so
right now have spoken more about the
small intestinal organized which are
more hollow in nature where the apical
side is towards interior as I mentioned
and the Bessel virtual side is on the
exterior but some organize definitely
grow as solid ball like structures or we
call them the compact organoid and for
them the polarity might be different but
definitely the quality is there it's
just that it's not always on the integer
or the exterior
I'm wondering about the apical basal
polarity of the epithelial cells in
organoids
since the nutrients are essential
nutrients available in culture are on
the outside of the orgonite what a
nutrient transporters be localized
basally thus suggesting that organize
are not exactly polarized as in vivo
um so nutrients available so I think got
the organize the way they grow the
nutrients are actually a will they can
actually go through because it's not
really a very solid structure right so
there is some kind of passage of the
nutrients or them of the media into the
interior also so they do pass through a
bit and so I I don't think anybody has
checked out it's a very good question
and I don't think anybody has really
checked if it's completely exactly like
how it is in vivo but I do feel that I
mean at least functionally we do see a
very distinct polarity of ethical and
relative side yeah
now our next question for coal culture
system does the ratio of immune cells
and organized matter
um I think yes because definitely an
overcrowding or immune immune cells we
have to always maintain any kind of Co
culture you have to maintain a balance
between the cell type and because the
media also has to be supplemented for
both the immune cells and for the
organoid person so yes definitely it
should not be overcrowded because you
also should be able to really see the
movement of the immune cells towards the
organoid and so yes I think the number
does matter or the ratio does matter
in triple coal culture did did you try
or in visage other cells by the mewn
sawl nerve cells for example no since we
haven't done yet
no unfortunately we haven't tried that
but it will be very interesting to do
that right now what we have done on
right now is isolating the PBMC from the
blood fraction and we cultures those we
actually the T cells from them and also
come culture all the PV ends together
and then we put them along with the
organoids to grow but TS so it will be
very interesting to put other cell types
also definitely
dr. data how long can microbes grow in
organoids and is it possible to culture
them long term so this is again a
question of what kind of microbe well
you're talking about so because for some
pathogenic microbes for example we have
tried Shigella we also studied
Cryptosporidium so these microbes are
really partitioning and so once you
inject them you for sugar lines in the
case of Shigella for example the
organoid architecture is completely
disrupted in three days or even less
actually whereas for comment two
microbes these can be grown for at least
seven days usually and then what we do
is we passage these organoids and we
have seen that these microbes can
actually persist so these have been
grown for at least three to four weeks
in our in a Lafayette
argue media components for healthy and
tumor organized the same
no essential components are the same for
example we do have to add some growth
factors for the cells to survive but
definitely because in the case of again
the most common type that we study
colorectal cancer most of the correct or
cancer or noise are air mutants for a
PSP and there is a vent activation so we
can leave out wind from our conditioned
media and they are really happily
growing without these external factors
but of course the basic I think the
basic factors are very similar but you
can remove factors and so there is a
difference in the healthy and you can of
course grow them in the same media as
healthy organoids the cancer ignored but
you don't really need to you can remove
some components yes
now when our large animal model or human
human clinical trials expected our very
space soon actually so I think for the
human clinical trial we are for cystic
fibrosis they are not the cancer but for
cystic fibrosis we have already tested
drugs and we have been able to make
organized from the patient and prescribe
them the medicine which was actually
most efficient for them this has been
already done a but for cancer I would
say we are looking at the four to five
years and it should be definitely be in
in clinical trials by then
now our next our next question is a
two-part question how is drug testing
performed on 3d organoids and are the
number of cells in each organized the
same if not then how does one account
for the difference in number / organoids
yeah that's one interesting thing that
we observe and organize all the time but
even if we inject our in even if you've
seen the same number of organized or a
toy cells when when we are forming the
organism at the first day they grow
differently and the organoid size varies
from drop to drop
so for drug testing what we do is before
we actually perform the test we shear
them or kind of make them s in yourself
and then we place them in the 384-well
plate us or 96-well plate whichever is
keeping you and if we let them grow for
two to three days so that they become
mini organized and that is when we do
the drug testing and of course when we
played them before the drug testing we
make sure that the same number of cells
have been plated so this is how right
now we are performing all our
experiments and we use a machine called
multi drop which makes sure that same
number is distributed
how do you manage bacterial growth
shegella is fostering bacteria after
Michael injection and do you add some
extracellular antibiotics such as
gentlemen
actually no we we grow them without any
antibiotic because these bacteria of
course would not like antibiotic in the
media so we have we always have a
control and when we inject we have the
injected bacteria and the growth and
without any pen strep so the idly the
organoid media has a benefit in
streptomycin and promotion but when we
are going these organoids in with
bacteria we do leave out every kind of
antibiotics from from the media
now do you keep the cytokines in the
media for organized immune co-culture do
we keep the cytokines in the media we do
we do they are the same and the media
because I think some of the cytokines
are very essential for the growth and so
we do keep the organoid culture media
same and then we supplement some which
would help the growth of the immune
cells now doctors are our next question
do you have any idea of the number of
cells inside and organoid like maybe
even a rough number
and that's I think it's very variable to
be honest because of so far if we see
the small intestinal organized there are
some which are really small which will
be a few thousand or yeah I would say
one to two thousand very small organized
whereas the bigger ones would have ten
to fifteen thousand organized cells in
one organ right so it is really very
variable because if you see pictures of
organize how when we publish it's really
tough to mensch or spay that and these
are for small intestines organize even
between within the same kind of organize
but within individuals between different
individuals we see different sizes and
the way they grow oil are very different
so we cannot really say if that's a fire
number really
now when will organoid genetically
modified intestinal stem cell
transplantation or clinical trials be
expected um I think this is being tried
already because we have been able to use
CRISPR gas 9 - so for again cystic
fibrosis we could show that the mutation
could be reversed using things CRISPR
cast 9 and also for human cancers the
research is ongoing I think it will
again be a few more years to go to
actually reach a place where we can do
clinical files but it's in the future I
would say again 3 to 4 years to go
how long are organized differentiated in
differentiation media
this again is quite variable so the one
thing I think which always stands out is
that there is a lot of variability from
organoid to organize so for example when
we in culture small additional organize
we draw them we make them as in
organized in e/m or expansion media for
seven days and then we add
differentiation media which is without
the wind and like the nicotinamide for
example and we let them grow for seven
days so for small intestine we
differentiate them for seven days and we
see that most of the cells then
differentiate to us and enter enter
enter side or enter into prime fee for
liver organoids for example it's very
different liver org nodes there are two
different kinds that we have one is the
duct of ductal origin or the kalanchoe
site life and now we have really
recently developed a habit a site like
organoid and these actually take way
longer than which range from I would say
10 days to sometimes almost 4 weeks
now how many organoids per Terran should
you grow to represent the whole mutation
spectrum of a tumor this is a good
question because I think this was really
studied recently in a lab in a paper
where we could show that within the same
tumor there was a lot of heterogeneity
so ideally we should grow as many
organized or when we get the tissue I
would say we should mince it into as
many pieces as possible and grow them
into as many different lines as possible
and before we if you really want to do
drug testing because it is really
heterogeneous within the same not even
within the same patient but just really
within the same tissue a lot of
heterogeneity was observed so yeah I
would say as many as possible from the
same tissue resection
now as microinjection of organoids
better than infecting monolayers how
does one account for mo i yeah so I'll
detail of this microinjection for
organoids because we wanted to really
keep the 3d structure of the organized
intact and because we think the 3d
structure really helps us mimic the
invivo architecture and so i wouldn't
say this is better because definitely
better when you can actually do it for
some organisms so you cannot really
inject them or it's not possible so or
if you really have to maintain the my
very strict way then I would go for
monolayers but in the micro injection
procedure we cannot control for the mo
AI but we control for the amount of
microbes that we inject into each
organoid so that each organise has the
same amount of microbe at the end
and it looks like we have time for one
more question how was a triple pole
culture model help in immunotherapy
ah yeah so this is this is I think a
dream that we have to use the orgonite
cultures to really study how these three
things come together the microbes and
the immune cells and epithelial
organoids
because two recent studies have shown
that even in humans the responders were
the responders to immunotherapy drugs I
had a different microbiome as compared
to the non-responders and so there is a
definite clue in there that the
microbiome does play a role in
immunotherapy drug response and so the
idea would be if we can have the
organized from a single patient and then
we can have the microbiome isolated from
the patient and of course like the
immune cells from the same person
we basically mimic the person in a plate
if ii say so and we will be able to test
drugs and really recommend what kind of
drugs would work for that person
specifically because not it's not
necessary that drug a as i mentioned
again in my presentation would work for
everybody so it's very variable so
ideally that is how i think it will be
helpful to tackle cancer in in general
and especially it will also help
immunotherapy to developing your therapy
drugs
thank you dr. data do you have any final
comments for our audience I would like
to thank everybody for such great
questions and for coming and listening
to the webinar and I had to create them
and I hope I was able to make them a bit
more aware about what organizers can do
and excite them about organoids and the
future
thank you again doctor dozen for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank loggers and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through April of
2019 Labyrinth will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed days
live event until next time goodbye